foreign  25 players in the NBA they want us to  start at 25. oh how do we do that that's  Rudy Pascal damn Kyrie yeah I think Rudy  gobert deserves to be right here 23.  Kyrie 22.  Pascal goes at 21. Zion Williamson  Jalen Brown lay it down let's play  Auntie Davis on the next James Harden is  at number 15 14. Paul George's heads  Damon Lillard is Tails  tails is at 14. and Paul George at 13.  John Rand is going 12. hey younger than  11 that's the number Kevin Booker Jimmy  Butler  Tatum Falls perfectly right now Kawaii  at seven boom we at number six  on the beat at six is it LeBron Luca KD  where's your LeBron LeBron yeah I'm  still top five number four Kevin Durant  Kevin Durant  step is number two and number one is  jokic Gianna says zero